read the script fantastic give me just
one moment
please
all right go right ahead okay as chair
of the children house and family law
committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
some committee members are participating
in this meeting from the
lobby
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the house con
house children and family law committee
it may be followed by an executive
session that's not really happening
today but that's what i'll normally read
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court's website
the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should call 271 3600
or email hcs
at legg.state.nh.us.com
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
the staff assisting on this meeting is
christina dyer
researcher from the house committee
services
please note that all votes are taken
during this meeting
shall be done by roll call
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
thanks do we really have to take
attendance for today christina
i would um just because it's being
recorded okay
so just for future reference normally
representative um caroletta alessia has
graciously agreed to be
our um committee clerk
she was um the committee clerk my first
time i was a chair so nothing against
you pap but i figure you're gonna be
busy
being like the ranking member or
something right
so um i have asked caroletta alessia and
i honestly think that in these times
it's very good for caroletta and i just
show our good working relationship
where she is a democrat and i am a
republican
so let's and that's the only time we're
going to use the r d words again
okay because we're just all here to do
what's best for the children and the
family of our state but
um who's going to take the roll call
will that be you christina
i can't if you like i'm i prepared to
take oh you are
oh well by all means please
okay if i mispronounce your name please
correct me
and i will do my best not to ever do it
again
the chair kimberly rice present
and i am in the lob in a room by myself
cassandra levesque
cody bellinger it's belanger man but i'm
here
belindra thank you sir i met you
deborah starts with an h
and i will just interrupt if folks could
say where they are and if they are alone
to be in compliance i apologize i'm here
in my home alone
minus the three dogs just to balance it
alone okay
thank you i have a deborah a
h or ch
that's representative bachelor yeah
okay is she here please
no representative
deborah de simone i am here
i'm in my home and i'm alone
my husband will be in later thank you
denise smith i am here
i am in my dining room um i may have
a child or two walk through um doing
remote learning
um
you erica connors
um erica is actually not on our
committee
that's an error she is on um i think
it's operandi or something yeah
thank you i must have gotten the old
sheep
yeah gabby grossman
hi everyone it's good to see all your
faces the familiar ones
um it's gabi grossman thank you
and i am present i've got i'm home and i
have two
remote learners in the house
thank you
john lewicky i'm here
alone thank you
i am at home thank you
josh ukila
uh present home alone
melissa litchfield
do you have she appears to be frozen
uh-oh are you able to hear me now
if we can hear you a little bit yes it
might help to turn your
your video off sometimes that helps with
the feed
okay do you hear me better now
yes thank you probably because i have
three of my children
thank you patrick long
i'm at home i'm alone and i'm here
thank you peter
petrigno hi i'm
home in my office alone
thank you did a nice job by the way with
the pronunciation
thank you very much
uh sophia
thank you yes sophia was your present i
am in my car
alone thank you
caroletta alicea i am home alone
can you just call on representative
levesque again because
you see her name on the screen
cassandra levesque
yes i am here i am in my
kitchen alone people may be coming in
and out
depending on if they want food
okay all right
all right madam chair thank you so much
so first i want to start off by saying
um thanks so much for
you know being on this committee i am
i personally love this committee i love
the work we do
and i think that we are just so
responsible in our
our work and i think that we set a good
example for the rest of the committees
in the house
with our bipartisanship and the way that
we all really
try to work together um
some of my expectations as chair is that
we are
always respectful to each other
um there you know leave the r d at the
door
because kids don't care kids don't care
if you're a republican or a democrat
you know and we're just supposed to be
looking out for what's best for them
and you know we're not going to agree on
everything that's
that's you know obvious but we really
really do
try to come to agreement on all our
bills
you know every sometimes you know people
just have to give a little
and some you know it's just the way it
is
you know but um i really really want us
to all be very respectful to each other
and you know really be friends because
i consider all my the committee members
that are returning from last year to be
my friends and i'm really excited to
gain new friends
so um i just i'm really looking forward
to this term
not not that last term was bad last term
was great
um representative long did a fabulous
job as chair
and uh you know and i think we lost some
really good members that we had
but um i think we've gained some really
good members also
so just to go over a few things so you
all know i i have i've asked
representative alecia to be
the committee clerk when she graciously
graciously accepted that's a big job
um and you know representative desimone
is the vice chair and she will also be
um the committee member that is our tech
support person
to help you know help me keep
everybody who wants to speak and all of
that in order
i have asked representative litchfield
to be our committee whip
well that doesn't that's just for the
republicans but anyways
um so um that's where we are
on that
so before the meetings we need to make
sure
everyone identifies one email address
for the use of the gym
zoom invitations okay and that's how
we'll know who's coming on
and and representative lewicki will make
sure that we have your phone number
so that you can um be identified and we
don't have to every time say who's that
number there
um going on and you know the um
the individual zoom invitations will be
sent out to each one with their own
specific link um
let's see if you're unable to attend
if you could just you know let me know
you know every things happen all the
time and we all have very busy lives
um you know but just let me know because
i i will try to hold off on you know if
i know
you're going to be just too late i'll
try to hold off but i really am a
stickler for starting on time
because the public comes to our meetings
they're expecting them to start at a
certain time
and i don't want them sitting and
waiting for 20 minutes because we're not
on time
um so um i do ask that everyone
you know be on time because i'll start
it i'll start
on time whether they're not you know so
if you want to let me know if you're
going to be a couple of minutes i can
drag things out a little bit when i
start the meeting but
we will always you know be starting on
time
um do not share your zoom link with
anyone else it's specific to you
um and you should always try to enter
the meeting
you know 10 to 20 minutes um
ahead of time that way we can make sure
all the kinks are worked out and you
know
we're not running into any problems
because as you know this is really new
for all of us
even though we've been doing a lot of
the zoom meetings we just want to make
sure that you know we have everything
under control and ready to go when it's
time to go and and not keep the public
waiting
um we're going to you know
observe committee decorum um so if
you're in
committee and and you want to ask a
question a question of the chair a
question of the person testifying or
whatever use the raise your hand
thing on the zoom thing you can uh raise
your hand and
you know um deborah will be helping
representative g simone will be helping
me
keep track of you know who raised their
hand i will always try to go
in order but keep in mind we have a lot
of things going on at the time so please
be patient with me
um and and you know
you don't speak until you're recognized
that's just
you know proper committee to quorum um
if you could today yeah is an exception
but going forward if you can have your
video on during a public hearing i think
it means a lot to the public they get to
see who they're talking to
they get to see you know they they know
that you're paying attention to their
testimony because
while you know this may not have
affected you this has been something
deeply personal in their life and and
they want to know that people are
listening
but one thing about our committee is
it's very emotional
um not everything is black and white um
there's a lot of emotions behind
everything
so we always want to you know be
respectful and make sure we're paying
attention to the people who are
testifying
um the chat feature will not be on
um and we but we can text or email
during
um the hearing if if we you know if
someone has an issue and
you know um i'm sure
hello sorry
sorry no don't be sorry
yeah i will last that you remain muted
and then um
you know until you're you're asked to
talk that way we don't get the
background noise we don't you know
um because i understand things happen
and it's it's different when you're how
my dog would would be jumping up on me
trying to tell me a whole story
in the middle of a meeting so um you
know if if
if you if you mute we we avoid that
um let's see
um really quick i want to touch on
executive
sessions i know there's been a lot of
talk about executive sessions
um we those are going to be hybrid
um most of you know i had covid
i am not taking chances with anyone
um so the
they will be hybrid you can if you
choose to come to the state house and
wear a mask
then great but if you don't want to stay
home
and you can do it this way but your
video must be
on because we have to know who is voting
we have to be able to see that it's
really you voting
and not your neighbor that came over to
sit in your seat
so you could go walk your dog or
something like that
so you know those are um i i just wanted
to
let everyone know that so it could you
know ease your mind
um a little bit also christina dyer
is our committee researcher and
our committee assistant right christina
well actually um i won't be the
committee assistant that will actually
be lindsey forcier
uh who hasn't quite returned yet but i
will i am the researcher for the
the committee and for right now you're
you're kind of assisting me right
correct awesome
that's great thank you so much so
anytime you need
something look into or something and you
want to have um
christina do that that request goes
through the chair
so you bring your request to me and and
i then bring it to
um christina i don't ever deny anyone's
request for anything because we all want
to have all the information we want to
have
and so
i think that's about it as far as that
goes
it looks like i think that last count i
can't remember if it was 17
or 19 bills that we'll have coming to
our committee
um we will be doing we will have one set
day a week i don't know what that day is
yet
and we will be going from nine to five
because we we want to get our work done
so you know one day a week as soon as i
know
that day i will definitely let all of
you know
but we will and we will be going full
days
to um get our work done because that
is the people that have been here before
know we have some bills where
yeah we
get a lot of people to come in and
testify on them it's emotional
it's a long day um but let's get it done
because these
you know a lot of these people have
waited long enough for some results
in their cases and and lives
um
uh what else was i gonna say i don't
know do you guys have any questions for
me
um if you have a question that's the
practice using the raise your hand thing
and then i believe that for right now
christina is going to
um run that for me thank god because i
forgot my mouse for my
laptop and i'm not really good without
it
but so does anyone have any questions
it looks like representative yokela has
his hand up hey
representative yokela how you doing
i'm fine um i have a question about uh
your statement that people need to be
in uh have their video on
during during voting for executive
sessions so i i think there's one person
that's
on this that is on via
phone call right so are you saying that
phone calls would not be allowed during
executives not during executive sessions
so we will work with representative
lewicki to see if we can come to
um a solution for that but we do we do
have to know
that it's actually the person voting but
we will work on that
okay this is representative can you can
you wait to be recognized representative
let me just make sure that
representative yokela is done
um yeah i mean it seems like it's going
to be
like there was someone earlier that was
having connection issues
and they suggested turning off the the
um
video so that they could be heard it
seems like there's going to be
uh we're just opening up to a lot of
problems
so when we get to a boat okay
they can turn their video back on
representative lewicki
can certainly come um in the building
for
exact session if he wants um
you know that's that's a choice he has
but the
speaker's office is working on ways to
help
make this work
you know what i'm saying because you
have to know who's
who's voting i i can't have somebody's
mother-in-law sitting there saying their
you know representative de simone and i
don't know that
i i understand this i'm concerned i mean
we're working on it
we are working on things and just so you
know that
the only time time this meeting has to
be shut down
is if there's a technical problem on
this end
okay if if somebody's internet is down
somewhere else that just
for the public that does not mean that
we have to shut down the meeting
right um it's only if
on our end there is a connectivity
problem
okay so um i you know i know that these
are
these are new times i don't like this i
can't wait for the day that we can all
be together again that you know i the
day i can hug my friends again
and you know we're all in the same room
and
and stuff i can't wait for that
unfortunately that time just is
not now um you know unless you choose to
you can come in here we will be socially
distanced we'll have masks
but the new um air things with the uv
lights have been put in
today um into the rooms so those will be
working
um you know we're really taking a lot of
precautions so people have choices
yeah except for the public when we're
not letting the public end
but what were you going to say
representative wiki
no thank you madam chair um as of now
and probably until the end of this month
i am still on a
dial-up phone connection and i cannot
possibly do video i am happy
as i said in messages to the speaker and
the clerk to come in
and sit in a room by myself at the lob
or
in a room with others
perfect okay like i said we're you know
we're working on all of this i think
we'll have like what
it won't be us that that meets next week
there'll be one
see how it goes you know um see how all
of this works
you know because we also have you know i
had questions about
um people calling in from out of new
hampshire
right i mean we represent new hampshire
so i don't want
10 people calling in on a bill from new
york city
right because they're not new hampshire
and you know as you know new hampshire
we do things our own ways so we have to
you know
we're there's a lot of kinks that we're
working out and
you know it but i really have faith that
it will all work out
um who had the next question
we have um representative padlong
okay representative long hi
hi hi thank you madam chair
um now do we know the capacity in the
lod
is there not that i know of yet but it
looks like it will be
um wherever the double room is
put right because we're going to use
double rooms
six feet apart for the people that come
and masks one at
one end of the hall the other at the
other
other end of the hall we're working on
staggered arrival times
so one committee starts at this time
another committee will you know start at
this time something like that
um like i said it's also new but you
know our main priority is just making
sure that
everyone is safe okay and the
um is this the hybrid just for
exact sessions nope hybrid is for um
for both hearings absolutely yeah yeah
um and uh and you're you're when you
find out the day you'll let us know what
day you're oh definitely right away yeah
yeah so you don't anticipate a couple
days just
one day one day all day
yeah um a week you know um right
until we get our work done but yeah i
because with only
17 to 19 bills i don't think we need two
days a week i think we can get
a lot a lot done in a day i think there
might be a couple of bills that are
going to take
um a longer period of time okay
but um other than that i i think we'll
be able to get a lot done
you know as long as we're you know on
time and and just
sticking to the script you know
but uh right i mean i really believe we
can do it
okay representative wazir had a 1 30
appointment that's why you're not going
to see her on here
at the dentist yeah she told me she had
to go to the dentist
great thank you thank you okay
who's next
nobody has their hand raised at the
moment
okay no other questions wow you guys are
good
but um so and like i said you know
be patient with me be patient with
representative desimone
and representative alessia this is you
know all new to us
representative long had some practice at
the end of
of last term so but this is um
all new to us and i have just never been
a fan of technology
so you know here we are but um
nobody has any other questions nothing
nothing
you did such a good job why didn't you
representative
you did such a good job
oh you're so sweet thank you um
but yeah i i think you know
that that will be let me just go over my
notes again real time
real quick to make sure that i
don't miss anything okay we do have some
hands now it looks like a representative
alicia has a question and followed by
representative
long okay great representative alessia
oh you need to unmute
there you are thank you madam chair my
question is regarding
the possibility of someone recording
our session and i know that there's
there can be issues with that so just to
share with everyone are we allowed to
record the sessions or not
so that people will know in in advance
well i know that it's
it's being recorded right now
um as far as the outside i
it's also being streamed on youtube yeah
each of the sessions
yeah so i mean it's out there
i suppose if if somebody's gonna record
it they're gonna have it
anyways and we'll have the original but
i don't know if that's an
option for someone who's not a panelist
you know what i mean christina do you
know if that's the case
uh no i don't believe that someone who's
not a panelist can do it
but i can say that these are archived on
the house of representative website so
anyone can go back and take a look at
the the recording at any time
okay great so thank you on your best
behavior
representative long you were nagged hey
thank you madam chair
um do you anticipate next week starting
hearings or
not for this committee i don't
anticipate that
i do anticipate that something will
start next week
but i don't think it's this one because
i think we're going to have a trial
run with i hope they don't pick this
committee because i really don't want to
make us
look you know but um
you know if i i just uh
i'm just not sure yet you know as you
know we were really behind
the timeline with the um
you know the passing of the speaker and
uh
then of course i got sick so that really
threw me
back even more but um yeah we're really
we're really working diligently to get
things up and running
and get um you know in a safe
way for everyone great
thanks thank you thanks
anybody else so what i would like to do
then
is i'm gonna i would like to call on
each one of you and you can just give a
little overview of yourself introduce
yourself to the committee
and you know tell a little bit about
yourself you know why did you choose
this committee and
and all of that so um i'd like to start
with
representative december
there we go why thank you madam chair
it will be a pleasure to work with you
my name again
is uh deborah desmoney i prefer to be
called deb
i'm from uh atkinson for
35 years i've been
uh blessed to be able to serve
on children and family law in the past
this is my seventh term
i think that children and family law
committee
has one of the most important tasks
because everything
we pass out of this committee or not
pass
out of this committee affects another
family's life
this has been a passion of mine since
forever
i'm really enjoying uh seeing that
um representative long representative
alicea petrigno
and grossman um
levesque yo keller you're all back of
course our
esteemed chair representative rice i
look forward to working with everyone
uh as representative rice said i'm the
vice chair
so if you can't get your question to
representative rice
by all means get your question to me
i will do my best to
get the answer for your question and
look forward to
a wonderful term thank you
thanks so much representative desimone
next i'm going to go to representative
long
thank you madam chair i'm uh pat long
i'm a manchester uh rep
and uh this is my eighth term for
terms on children and family uh and i'm
looking forward to doing some uh
good work uh you know of the uh
i'm proud along with the committee to
have the governor sign our bill so our
work didn't go for not
so that was good um so
i'm looking forward to what we could do
this term thank you
okay thank you representative along next
representative alessia
thank you madam chair i'm so excited to
be back on children and family law
i'm excited to have you thank you
i think it's the beginning everything
starts at home
in in my heart so it's very
it's a very important committee to me
we make decisions that really affect the
entire state
and all of our families and children and
i
i'm so excited to get to work with all
of you to make
really good things happen for them
this i was on three terms and then i
worked in georgia doing voter
registration
and then i chose to run again so
technically
four terms but i missed i missed one
term
so again i look forward to working with
all of you and if you have any questions
um please my email is caroletta.alyssa
dot leg.state.nh dot u s please you can
email me anytime and my phone number is
738-1561 so
anytime and i just want to add
madam chair is very open to
hearing uh people who maybe have
different
ideas or suggestions
so i you know suggest that if
if you have an idea or something that
could make things better for us
or different please if you feel
comfortable
contact her i want to throw you out
there like that
madam chair but i know that you are
welcoming too
any almost anything so thank you
thank you okay um next we'll go with
um representative petrino
i hope you gotta unmute can't hear you
there we go thank you madam chair i am
peter petrino from milford
for some strange reason my last name is
really challenging for many people to
pronounce
i think it's the gn that in italian we
don't have that sound in english but
that's okay i'm not offended it's all
good
i'm entering my second term uh in the uh
house and as a member of the children
and family law committee
i'm a retired educator i taught high
school for over 40 years
and aside from education children and
family law was the best fit for me
and i'm very happy to be back so thank
you
we're happy to have you okay so i'm just
going to go like along my screen in no
particular order so i don't want to
offend anyone you know um
so next up i have representative smith
sorry um hi i'm denise smith i'm from
pelham um
i am um the
stay-at-home mom of three adopted
children
um so family uh law makes sense to me
um kim asked me to join the committee
because of my
experience with adoption i'm sorry i
have to let my dogs out
um and uh this is my first term i'm
looking forward to
working with all of you and um
i am um hoping that i
bring something to the table you'll
bring a lot to the table
don't sell yourself short
thank you hey so next i have um
representative grossman
hi everyone um it's gabi grossman and i
like representative petrino also have a
funny name
so gabby like bobby i guess if that's
easy for people
um so this is my second term returning i
live in exeter i have three boys a
soon to be 16 year old son with autism
and i have twin boys that are middle
schoolers um
i am chair of the bipartisan disability
caucus so if you have any questions
related to that
my background i was also an educator
prior to having my kids
and then i've been at home with them
since
i had them and then i'm also an artist i
have a studio
um so and we recently became
campground owners so we made a big
shift in our life and we bought
a campground in ashland new hampshire
with a hundred
um sites so if you're into camping come
visit us this summer
oh that is so cool i didn't know that
awesome congratulations
thank you and thank you we just might
because i love ashland we go up there a
lot
awesome thanks so much okay
representative bellander hi everybody my
name is cody belanger i'm from epping
i'm very excited to be here to the point
where my wife teased me that i started
crying
um that i was given a put on this
committee
um not only i'm trying not to cry right
now um
not only am i a student and a child of
the system both at dcyf and juvenile
justice
but my wife and i are also um we have
taken on the custody
and uh hopefully the soon-to-be role of
adopting our nephew
um so yeah giving me goosebumps cody
really i'm
i'm like my eyes are watering right now
and i don't even know why
but i am very excited to be here i'm
excited to work under um representative
rice and representative de simone
i cares so very much about the system it
has its quirks it has its moments but
i'm hoping that we can be a part of the
change and
effect for the better sorry
thank you so much representative
belanger okay next representative
mitchfield
where'd she go there we go can you try
again
a verizon commercial
[Laughter]
dude are you able to hear me i can hear
you now yeah
so one of the one of the things i'm
wondering
um melissa is if you turned
if you turned off the audio and called
in
on your phone to use the audio that way
and we just had your video
i wonder if that would work better
what i mean like we can turn off the
audio on your computer
call in with your phone because there
should have been a phone number where
you could call in also
and use that for the audio
and as long as you don't have them both
together i think we'll be okay
is that okay christina absolutely
executive decisions like oh no that's
perfect yeah we always recommend calling
in if the audio isn't working
thanks for your patience everybody we'll
get this figured out
so um representative litchfield while
you're calling in
why don't i go to representative lebeck
and then we'll come back to you okay
okay thanks all right representative
lebeck
hello my name is representative
cassandra levesque
i also go by cassie
this is my second term on children
family law
i got involved by
a a project that i started when i was
15 16 years old and i put in legislation
with the help of my local representative
to unchal marriage here in new hampshire
took a little bit but we
got it raised to 16 and
when i was 19 years old i was asked to
run and
i never regretted it since and i decided
to run
again and i have a
girl scout troupe of brownies and
juniors
and i started that when i was 18.
um yeah i have always volunteered with
kids
and girl scouts and i worked at
a summer camp since i
was able to and i really
am passionate about making sure that
kids voices are heard
and making sure that we
can do what's best for them
awesome thanks so much representative
evac
okay representative litchfield are you
hooked up now
if you unmute your phone
okay i can hear you just turn off the
audio on your computer
so you can click and it'll say um
where i think where your video is or
maybe it's no over by mute it'll say
um
leave computer audio
if you click the click the little arrow
near the microphone where it says you
commute
about on my telephone right now my no on
your computer
just because we're getting feedback from
do you know what i'm saying
isn't that strange there we go
oh yeah because i okay now try
how you doing see i can hear myself
uh oh now i i lost her there too
can't i'm just oh there you are okay
peter and i'm just on my my um
it's still not coming through well i
don't know why
[Music]
all right she's frozen up again
i'm sorry um melissa
we're gonna have to work on that i don't
know why that's not working well
um representative yokela
hi um my name is uh representative
joshua kella
um i live in
fremont representing fremont brentwood
in danville
i this is my second term um both
times on children and family law
and i
have a wide range of topics i work i
work um at an rv dealership
and i um
deal with the sales tax and stuff uh
that they collect all across the all
across the nation
so it i'm spending time always
researching
sales tax and so this is a
happy distraction from that
and um and so yeah i'm looking forward
to
another session and looking forward to
trying to
get some movement on some of these
important topics that we hear in this
committee so
just looking forward to it thanks hey
thanks so much
um representative yokela and then um
representative lewicki
welcome back
yes this is john lewicky representative
from mason and
brookline i am entering my second term
non-consecutive i was on children and
family law in the term previous to the
last
i've spent most of my life working as a
systems and electrical engineer
and this is somewhat foreign country to
me and
i was on children family law before and
i do uh with many of the people who are
on this call
and i do understand how emotional it is
and
how sometimes it is rather draining
that's all i have all right thanks so
much representative the wiki welcome
back
all right representative litchfield do
we want to try this one more time
no
okay well we're going to get that um
figured out
trust me i've been taking notes and plan
to go back over to the speaker's office
after this is over
to bring up um some of the concerns that
um
that i've noticed and everything um
but does anyone have any other questions
for me
or um you know anything that
that you know you want to bring up uh
so just so you know if you do come in
for the committee there's um
you can bring like a bottled water but
there's you can't eat food while you're
at the thing i ask that you
keep your um cell phones you know
really to a minimum especially
especially if someone is testifying
because there's nothing worse than
someone who thinks you're not listening
or that you don't care
so it's really important that you know
you're really focused when people are
testifying
uh they will be able to see us there
will be a big screen
um tv in the room so it's going to be
um interesting to say the least
but um you know so those are just some
things that if you come in
um from the um
you know to come actually into the
committee
so i i want to say that we said today if
you if as long as we are six feet away
we will not have to wear a mask while
we're sitting
we're also trying to get the um the
plastic partitions that would go up in
between us
um so we're looking into that also but
if you get up from your seat you need to
wear a mask
if you are coming into the building you
need to wear a mask until you are seated
in your seat
okay because regardless of how you feel
about it okay we have staff here who are
very concerned and we have to think of
them
also so um
there's that um and i said you know no
food keep your electronic use to
a minimum um
let's see uh madam vice chair did i
forget anything
probably but
thank you madam chair i don't think you
forgot anything
um i think
that as long as we understand
that the perception of our committee
is what the public sees and if we
treat each other with the ultimate of
respect
and leave our party lines at the door
then the general public who testifies
feels more comfortable they feel that
their words are not falling
on deaf ears
we need to respect each other by
referring to each other as
our chair has today representative
grossman representative levac whomever
but always use the word representative
that shows that we respect each other
and it shows the general public that
that's the case
and we're serious and we're professional
um i will say um that
i believe our chair
when she tells us because i've heard in
in meetings um that our
safety as law as well as the employee's
safety
is utmost um so
whether you feel safe or not
is your choice and other than that
to to back up your words that's all i
have to say
thank you so much i guess i i forgot to
kind of introduce myself
so i'm representative kim rice this is
my fourth term in the house
this is my second time as a chair and i
also serve as the um speaker pro tem
and i will also be serving on judiciary
so i'll be a little busy so bear with me
please
um i got into this because my
husband was dragged through the mud in
the family court system and his poor
kids um were dragged through it who i'm
happy to say now all three of them live
with us
even though they're adults
um i love them don't get me wrong um
and so you know but i've learned a lot
and i
i really say to um open your ears and
listen
if so if one of your bills doesn't pass
because trust me
many of mine haven't there's a reason
um you know keep in mind we can't pass a
bill that's going to affect
five people but hurt thousands you know
we have a big responsibility a
responsibility that i don't take lately
and um you know so i i just want to
welcome you all
and thank you so much i know you all
didn't choose children and family law
but for those that did choose it i
really appreciate it for those that
stepped up to take the assignment thank
you so much i
you know i i take great care and and
who's on this committee i
i do take great pride in it so um
i want to thank you all for showing up
today
and as soon as i know what day will be
our day i will let you know
and we can go from there any questions
you have please
take down my cell phone number which i
am not going to announce over the air
because i've
ended up having several people
that i don't even know texting me all
the time and you know
um i will tell you sundays are my day
with my family
so if i don't necessarily respond that's
why
um but um you know
shoot me an email and i'll i'll send you
my cell and because i don't have any
problem with anybody texting me it's so
important to keep the lines of
communications open in our committee
so that's about all i have and uh
so thanks so much for coming and i will
see you guys soon
take care thank you
thank you representative rice and thank
you everyone else
and thanks so much christina oh yes
thank you have a great day everyone all
right take care bye you